bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france on commence avec vous
laurent alexandre on l'a dit une
manifestations simultanées dans
plusieurs pays européens et notamment à
bruxelles c'était important d'organiser
une telle manifestation selon vous je
crois qu'il faut regarder les choses en
face
les dépenses de santé dans des pays
comme la france sont déjà absolument
considérable la santé c'est 10 % de la
richesse nationale en france
c'est absolument énorme et un effort a
été fait depuis deux ans qui est très
important donc il ne faut pas faire
croire aux gens qu'on va
considérablement augmenter le budget de
la santé parce qu'on est déjà au taquet
10% de la richesse nationale c'est
absolument énorme
donc il ne faudrait pas que vos
téléspectateurs imagine que l'on ne
dépense rien pour la santé une partie
très importante de la richesse nationale
et consacré à la santé et l'hôpital
représente à peu près la moitié des
dépenses de santé
le reste représentant les soins de ville
et la dépense médicamenteuse donc dans
les années qui viennent on peut faire
croire
on va pouvoir mettre des centaines de
milliards sur le système de santé mais
c'est un mensonge on ne pourra pas donc
il va falloir augmenter la productivité
rationaliser le l'hôpital j'ai exercé
trente ans à l'hôpital public j'étais
chirurgie n'eurent l'audio que je
connais un petit peu les les choses
magnifiques que fait l'hôpital et le
système de santé
je sais aussi qu'il y a des choses que
l'on peut rationaliser on peut diminuer
les durées de séjours en chirurgie en
développement la chirurgie ambulatoire
qui est sous développée en france la
france est un pays où l'acheter
obligatoire n'est pas à la hauteur de ce
qu'elle devrait être
donc si l'on fait de la démagogie
on va faire part aux gens qu'on va
pouvoir mettre beaucoup plus d'argent
dans la santé mais ça n'est pas réaliste
il va donc ce mari père martin est ce
que vous pensez que cette manifestation
aujourd'hui qui a été simultanées ont
l'a dit et dans toute l'europe va donner
plus de poids à vos revendications
je sais pas si elle va donner plus de
poids en tout cas elle monte
il ya un souci est qu'il ya un souci qui
dépasse bien au-delà de nos frontières
qui est un souci dans le paradigme de la
santé dans tous les pays du monde c'est
facile de dire qu' on ne pourra pas
débloquer des milliards mais la réalité
aujourd'hui la réalité du terrain c'est
que les patients sont en danger et les
patients c'est vous c'est nous et nos
familles et tous ces personnages sont en
danger parce que c'est quelque chose on
refuse de mettre de l'argent dedans on
refuse de mettre les moyens
on peut un système performant et en fait
là la santé il faut accepter de donner
des moyens pour du long terme
c'est vrai que c'est pas rentable la
santé c'est pas rentable et c'est normal
parce que c'est un investissement
c'est un investissement comme un autre
donc la santé il faut investir dedans
pour sa survive il faut investir dedans
parce que c'est important on le voit
aujourd'hui on a une pandémie nationale
internationale mondiale qui met à mal
toute l'économie
tout ça parce qu'il ya des gens qui ne
sont pas en capacité de de donner
l'argent donc on a besoin de donner les
moyens on a besoin pour nos patients et
en fait ce qu'on défend aujourd'hui
c'est l'accès aux soins et on montre
bien qu'on n'est pas des seuls en europe
on n'est pas les seuls dans le monde
puisque c'est un combat qui va jusque
dans le québec jusqu'au québec
donc on a vraiment besoin de ces moyens
là et c'est pas de la démagogie de dire
ça on a besoin de moyens
laurent alexandre la connexion a été
rétablie avec vous est ce que des moyens
pour le long terme ça peut être possible
malgré tout selon vous on peut répéter
mille fois on ne donne pas de moyens au
système de santé
c'est totalement faux l'effort que fait
la collectivité pour le système de santé
que ce qu'il s'agisse du canada de la
france de l'allemagne est absolument
énorme 10% de la totalité de la richesse
du pays et consacrer la santé c'est
absolument gigantesque
ce sont des sommes absolument folle qui
sont mises dans le système de santé donc
cessons de dire qu'il n'ya pas d'argent
dans le système de santé
il y à des sommes absolument incroyable
qui sont mises dans le système de santé
et pendant pendant la pandémie
on a réalisé des millions et des
millions de tests
on a mis
des moyens très importants au service du
système de santé
donc je le répète on peut répéter mille
fois qu'il n'y a pas d'argent dans le
système de santé
en réalité il ya 10% de la richesse
nationale qui est mise dans le système
ne semblait pas d'accord avec ce que
nous dit laurent alexandre mais c'est
hallucinant on ne vit que la wii a des
moyens mais tous les angles manque de
fer avec un milliard en moins
c'est-à-dire que tous les ans là on a
une pandémie mondiale qui montrent que
je ne sentais n'y a pas assez et un
moment de faire encore moins en compte
fermer des lits on a mis des personnes
sur des brancards dans des réfectoires
et on nous permet d'en on est encore en
train de dire oui mais vous fassiez des
économies c'est n'importe quoi
on en a besoin de moyens en fait oui
l'argent ça oui
la santé c'est de l'argent la santé ça
coûte de l'argent oui il ya des moyens
mais les moyens sont insuffisants
on dit pas qu'il ya pas de moyens on dit
juste qu'il n'y en a pas assez en fait
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas assez pour
prendre soin des patients correctement
pour être humain et pour pouvoir prendre
une en soi un patient de manière
correcte vous fêté de manière décente
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on prend des
patients en charge dans des réfectoires
parce qu'on n'a pas assez de lits parce
que le système est incapable de faire
face à n'importe quel événement
sanitaires de grande ampleur et ça c'est
la réalité
ça c'est ce qu'on voit tous les jours et
ça c'est ce qu'on vit tous les jours en
fait et c'est ce dont on a besoin c'est
pas c'est pas un caprice qu'on fait on
n'est pas en train de demander des
moyens pour pouvoir s'asseoir et aurait
passé une soirée tranquille
on est là parce qu'on veut on a besoin
pour nos soit pour le patient d'avoir
des moyens et de pouvoir les prendre en
charge correctement de manière décente
et c'est là où on n'est pas du tout
d'accord en fait et où on ne sera pas
c'est que dia des moyens qui sont donnés
on dit juste que de nous demander de
faire des économies tout le temps c'est
pas vivable et c'est tout en fait
et c'est nos patients sans paye le prix
c'est pas nous laurent alexandre on vous
retrouve une nouvelle fois comment vous
expliquez que le gouvernement ne
répondent pas favorablement à la demande
des soignants pour y revenir sur une
manifestation qui a également eu lieu
aujourd'hui à saint-ouen en
seine-saint-denis pour protester contre
le projet d'implantation du grand
hôpital nord qui va entraîner 300 lits 2
avec la fin des hôpitaux bichat et
beaujon comment vous l'expliquez il y a
trop de lits en france nous avons des
durées de séjour qui sont trop élevés il
y a beaucoup de chemin qui sont réalisés
à l'hôpital qui pourraient être
réalisées en hôpital de jour et en
chirurgie ambulatoire c'est la réalité
le le recours à la chirurgie ambulatoire
est en france encore insuffisant nous
avons l'habitude c'est d'avoir des
durées de séjour longue
elles ont beaucoup diminué depuis 50 ans
mais pas encore suffisamment donc notre
problème aujourd'hui c'est pas d'acheter
les nouvelles casquettes et les
intervenants par un peu son casque c'est
de rationaliser le système de santé
parce que nous avons besoin d'énormément
d'argent pour l'indépendance il va
falloir des centaines de milliards dans
les décennies qui viennent pour la
dépendance et donc la priorité dans les
années qui viennent
ça ne va pas être l'hôpital en aigu ça
va être la prise en charge la dépendance
compte tenu de l'explosion de la
dépendance dans nos pays qu'elle est
quelle évolution peut-on espérer avec
cette crise sanitaire où vous vous
disiez qu'il y avait trop d'hôpitaux
trop de lits pas redondant dans les
hôpitaux mais on en a eu besoin pendant
cette crise sanitaire ou laurent
alexandre on n'a jamais manqué de lit
pendant la crise sanitaire je vous
rappelle qu'on avait fermé les lits
d'aigus les lits de soins traditionnels
étaient fermées donc quand on regarde le
taux d'occupation des hôpitaux pendant
la crise du coc vide il était faible
parce qu'on avait fermé des services
entiers pour se concentrer sur ce qui
était le plus important qui était la
prise en charge de soins aigus et de
réanimation au sens large du terme
donc nous n'avons jamais manqué de lit
et je le répète dans les années qui
viennent
l'urgence c'est de mettre de l'argent
dans la dépendance parce qu'il va
falloir gérer l'explosion du nombre de
personnes âgées dépendantes qui est liée
à l'augmentation de l'âge moyen qui
hausse
alors alors que nous n'avons vous le
savez bien hélas toujours pas de
traitement de l'alzheimer et des
démences séniles ce qui fait exploser le
besoin de recours aux structures de
prise en charge des personnes âgées
dépendantes donc il n'y aura pas
significativement plus d'argent pour les
hôpitaux d'aigus
dans les vingt trente années qui
viennent on peut l'espérer mais cela
n'arrivera pas parce que la priorité du
système social noël de liège c'est la
dépendance et il va falloir mettre
énormément d'argent pour gérer
l'augmentation l'explosion du nombre de
personnes âgées dépendantes dans les
pays européens
merci beaucoup pour votre éclairage
laurent alexandre je rappelle que vous
êtes essayiste et chirurgiens à
bruxelles et merci à vous marie pierre
martin on va vous laisser rentrer pour
le couvre-feu membres du collectif inter
urgence merci à vous